après moult humour mouvement beaucoup de
demande de votre au port voici enfin un
nouveau 3t rue sur star wars que vous
attendiez depuis un moment
je suis très heureux de pouvoir faire
cette vidéo et vous avez le droit de
savoir pourquoi je n'ai plus fait de
star wars pendant un moment
star wars est une licence que j'adore
cependant je laime au même titre que de
nombreuses licences dont j'ai parlé dans
l'émission trois théories et justement
ma chaîne n'ait pas accès sans pour son
star wars
je veux et j'aime parler de théorie sur
tous les films et jeux que j'adore et
cela ne s'arrête pas seulement à star
wars et en voulant vous faire plaisir et
puis en voyant que ça marchait bien je
me suis enfermé un moment dans de
nombreuses vidéos star wars qui au final
ne me plaisait plus vraiment trop de
star wars tu le star wars et je n'avais
plus l'impression de faire de la qualité
et de la quantité et je me forçais à
faire ces vidéos
j'ai donc préféré faire une pause et
parlait beaucoup moins de star wars qui
n'est pas le sujet principal de ma
chaîne
le sujet principal sont les théories si
vous souhaitez en savoir plus sur les
soi disantes coulisses de la chaîne et
savoir ce que je prévois de faire
n'hésitez pas à me suivre sur twitter
pour être au courant de l'actu
bref j'espère que vous comprendrez ma
démarche et je suis très heureux de
faire cette vidéo car je vous ai pondu
et trouver trois théories aux petits
oignons qui devrait vous plaire
donc sans attendre voici les trois
théories que je vous propose
[Musique]
comme vous le savez l'actrice de leia
organa soit carrie fisher nous a
malheureusement quittés en décembre 2016
hommage à l et tout ceci va grandement
perturbé le futur des films star wars
je m'explique la mort de carrie fisher
fut un choc pour tout le monde aussi
bien fans que réalisateur l'actrice
devait jouer un rôle majeur dans les
prochains films star wars et carrie
fisher avait même tourné entièrement
star wars 8 avant de nous quitter il est
dit qu elle possède un grand rôle dans
ce dernier et qu'elle apparaît très
souvent cependant elle n'a pas eu le
temps de jouer son rôle dans star wars 9
et c'est là que de nombreux débats sont
arrivés tout d'abord une rumeur s'était
fait connaître disant que les gars
organa serait jouée en images de
synthèse étant donné que carrie fisher
nous a quittés mais ce fut très vite
démentie par disney où nous a ensuite
confirmé que leia organa ferait partie
de l'opus 9 en utilisant des images déjà
existante de l'actrice afin d'éviter les
images de synthèse mais après mûre
réflexion il a finalement été décidé
officiellement que carrie fisher soit
leia organa ne ferait pas partie de
l'opus neuf donc un mystère se crée
maintenant leia organa joue un rôle
apparemment majeur dans star wars 8 et
nous la verrons très souvent elle n'est
pas censé mourir dans le film car elle
était prévue pour encore un grand rôle
dans le neuf
néanmoins il faut savoir que le scénario
de star wars 8 n'a pas été changée alors
comment les organes à pourra-t-elle nous
quitter toute la question est là
disney ne peut juste pas nous dire
balayeur ghana nous a quittés dans une
galaxie on a verra plus non nous parlons
de leia organa joué par carrie fisher
légendes de l'univers star wars
que pouvons nous donc supposer déjà je
pense très certainement que les
écriteaux de l'épisode 9 au début de
chaque film star wars mentionnera une
part de la disparition de l'eia ce qui
nous éclairera très certainement
ensuite il faut savoir que le neuvième
opus de la saga sera celui qui clôturera
la nouvelle trilogie du 7 8 9 donc une
grosse guerre intergalactique sera de
mise
il se pourrait que l'eia disparaissent
dans un vaisseau lors de la guerre avec
une explosion pourquoi pas ou bien
peut-être que disney peut littéralement
se moquer de nous et dire que les ja
nous acquitter entre l'épisode 8 et 9
d'un accident ou bien d'une attaque
secrètes de ce nom je détesterais ceux
ci
mais une possibilité reste présente même
si on ne peut l'imaginer c'est qu'une
autre actrice prennent le rôle de l'eia
le scénario n'a pas été modifié et il
faut savoir que l' annonce officielle
parle du fait que carrie fisher ne sera
pas présent dans l'opus neuf mais il
n'est pas mentionné que leia organa ne
fera pas partie du film de plus les ja
possède un rôle clé dans les prochains
films
d'après de nombreuses informations cela
ferait très bizarre que l'eia suite à
une grande participation dans l'opus 8
soit complètement absente de l'opus 9
je sais que ça risque de chagriner
certains mais soucier réellement
possible et pourrait bien arriver je ne
sais pas ce que ça donnerait mais
l'avenir de l'eia est un mystère qui
reste entier et nous aurons la réponse
seulement en 2019
qu'en pensez vous cette théorie est
vraiment incroyable et j'espère qu'elle
vous plaira
la nouvelle mascotte de star wars et
maintenant bébé 8 et même s'il a
apprécié par la plupart des fans on ne
sait rien à propos de ce droid
on sait qu'il appartient soit disant à
pau damon et qu'il fait partie de la
résistance mais on en reste là
cependant un mystère pourrait bien
existé à propos du petit droïde tout
d'abord il faut savoir que bébé 8 est un
droïde unique en son genre d'après peau
d'iron ce n'est qu'un détail mais on va
le garder c'est un indice ensuite s'il
vous l'aviez jamais remarqué qu'elle
aurait les bébés 8 ne se sont jamais
croisés ou vu dans star wars 7
c'est très important ce que je vous dis
là car cela pourrait bien créer un
tournant dans les prochains films star
wars
cai lorraine mentionne toujours bébé 8
par le petit droïde et leur donne
toujours à ses troupes de ne pas
l'abîmer qu'ils doivent seulement
l'attraper général e qui interviendra
même pour lui dire de ne pas laisser vos
intérêts personnels interférer avec la
mission kyle lorraine et bébé 8 serait
donc lié et le film est bourré d'un
disent en accord avec cette théorie
je ne sais pas vous mais personnellement
j'ai toujours été surpris de la scène où
ray et fine doivent se cacher dans le
vaisseau de ran solo et chez wee bb 8 ne
se cache pas lui il reste avec anne solo
alors qu'il est recherché par tout juste
pourquoi
solo semble beaucoup apprécier bébé 8 et
bébé 8 aussi en retour
c'est ce que je comprends donc ils
doivent peut-être déjà se connaître mais
il ya aussi le retour à la résistance
bébé 8 vient de la résistance et semble
connaître tout le monde ce qui est
normal puisqu'il est avec pau damon mais
quelque chose m'intrigue réellement il
est donc aussi en compagnie de l'eia et
semble avoir toujours vécu dans la
résistance
donc il a forcément connus qu'à lorraine
alias ben solo à l'époque
néanmoins ce n'est pas le plus
intriguant encore le plus intrigant et
que kay lorraine est un skywalker du
sens de l'udc et anakin coule dans ses
veines
puis évidemment qu'elle aurait ni de
lettre son grand-père dark vador soit
anakin depuis toujours et dites-moi café
anakin durant sa jeunesse il a conçu
c3po les skywalker sont énormément doué
dans la mécanique
d'après ces théorique est lorraine
aurait conçu bébé 8 quand ils étaient
jeunes comme anakin avec c3po dans sa
jeunesse qu à l or n -b 8 ne se sont
jamais croisées dans star wars cette
benne demande de faire attention à lui
lors de sa capture et ordonne même de le
laisser tranquille quand ils tombent sur
veille cette théorie est parfaite et
pourrait bien vouloir dire quelque chose
qu'elle aurait les bébés 8 serait donc
lié et donc bébé 8 pourrait être un
élément perturbateur czekaj lorraine le
droid qui l'a conçue durant son enfance
pourra bien le faire changer d'avis sur
ses intentions
à voir ce qu'il se passera dans star
wars 8 mais ce serait un tournant
réellement intéressant
pour finir cette vidéo j'aimerais vous
faire part d'une petite théorie
intrigante
si vous avez vu l'opus est de la saga
star wars vous savez que r2d2 le droid
présent depuis le début de l'épopée est
hors service dans la nouvelle trilogie
il est comme dans une veille prolongée
cependant lorsque la basse terre qui
leur est détruite le droid se réveille
enfin et divulgue à la résistance la
carte qui permet de retrouver luke
skywalker et que tout le monde cherche
depuis un moment
néanmoins ce réveil soudain de r2d2
nouveau poste pas question pourquoi
maintenant et pourquoi pas avant savons
que c'est lui qui lui ordonnait de se
mettre en veille durant tout ce temps et
on suppose de par la célèbre image de sa
main robotisée sur le petit droïde et
qui lui a ordonné sûrement de se
réveiller au moment propice pour donner
son emplacement malgré le morceau
manquant tout d'abord l'udc n'a pas pu
envoyer un message depuis sa lointaine
planète tous les jedi utilisent la
technologie pour pouvoir s'adresser au
droid à distance à part si l'udc possède
un transmetteur d'aussi loin il n'a pas
pu être au courant de la destruction de
la ba starkiller pour dire à r2d2 de se
réveiller
d'après jj abrams le créateur de la
nouvelle trilogie r2 d2 se réveillerait
à cause du retour de bébés 8 lui
informant qu'ils possèdent le morceau de
carton manquants mais je trouve ça
étrange car cela voudrait dire que lucas
connaissance de bébés 8 cela pourra même
confirmé encore plus la théorie
précédente
l'udc or étant donné r2d2 de se
réveiller seulement lorsque la
résistance récupérerai le dernier
morceau de cartes par le biais de bébés
après tout le chaînon manquant et est
possédé par leur steak à ce mystérieux
personnage qui semble beaucoup connaître
les skywalker dont l'udc
ce n'est clairement pas hasard siège de
d2 s'est réveillé après la destruction
de la ba starkiller pour donner toute la
carte restantes lors du moment
victorieux et surtout en compagnie de
bébés 8% dans le dernier morceau
cela voudrait donc dire que le célèbre
jedi ce serait que tout ceci allait se
passer un jour ou l'autre et que c'est
pour ça qu'il s'est exilé il savait
qu'un jour ou l'autre la base ennemie
tomberait et aurait donc tout confièrent
de d2 se faisant passer pour entre
guillemets mort et qu'il devrait se
réveiller au moment précis où la base
serait détruite et que le morceau de
cartes seraient récupérés et vous qu'en
pensez vous cette saga est réellement
rempli de mystères et j'espère que ces
trois théories vous auront
n'hésitez pas à m'en faire part dans les
commentaires merci à ceux qui laisseront
un pouce bleus et qui partageront la
vidéo je vous invite aussi à me suivre
sur twitter pour les plus acharnés
d'entre vous je trouve que je ne le
partage pas assez souvent
bref que le lane alors soit avec vous
les amis cet état gorog
[Musique]